à tarde é que agradecer desde já o
convite vou falar vocês
evoluí tentar durante crime falar com
que a lembrança e tecnologia médica
tecnologia hoje impõe desafios à
liderança pouco a lembrança não está
preparada nomeadamente no eixo de
comunicação tanto sabemos é que vou
começar a encontrar um salto nas
conclusões
eu gostei de frente sabemos que a
tecnologia é sambar que todas as áreas
da organização influenciar a estratégia
nossa queria tirar a maneira como nos
relacionamos maneira como comunicamos e
acima de tudo
no global como a organização funciona
hoje em dia
pense nisto como exemplo onde está o
confessor podem estar diretamente como
eu podem estudar vilar nem como eu podem
ter uma reunião skype com erros
diferentes opções
imaginemos agora esse cenário se torne
um símbolo do facebook o elemento de
frente ao facebook do hawai cabanga
imagine o seguinte imagine quando vocês
pedem ajuda ao professor
vamos direcionar a questão do professor
e por isso lamentavelmente não respostas
dar
neste assunto dois dias coloca no seu
facebook pessoal
o vosso líder coloca não foi expulso ao
hotel que está de férias no hawai
como é que vocês acham que todos iriam
reagir
quem estaria ok asha queria compreender
esta utilização do facebook que iria
concordar com essa posição porque
acontece normalmente neste caso não é
tão grave mas imaginem que no contexto
de uma organização oliver dois dias
antes tinha dito que não ia atribuir os
prémios de produtividade porque as
condições não permitiam passar dois dias
tá no hawai weldel a vida pacata e
pessoal que tem
a questão é como é que os clubes dos que
agem os líderes têm que entender que as
tecnologias da informação e da
comunicação transfiguram por completo
esse processo de comunicação
outro exemplo uma reunião via galdi
hoje em dia toda a gente tem de estar
disponíveis ruídos tentados níveis
vamos fazer reuniões via skype em alta
neste tipo de reuniões podemos ter
pessoas de diferentes nacionalidades
hoje vivemos diariamente e fisicamente
com pessoas diferentes nacionalidades
a diferença é como é conviver motiva
seja sem que pois foram apenas virtuais
não tiverem contato físico é forma de
comunicar é a mesma como é que interagem
de rua assinamos como fugir e metal
empatia que falou há pouco ou aperto de
mão a forma de comunicar é diferente
também não vimos todos os gestos que
fazemos nós escrevemos um discurso forma
como ela entre potável porque nós é
completamente dissipada
neste sentido deve ser efetivamente que
a tecnologia é apesar de mudar o
contexto também é uma resposta a esse
contexto e este esta mudança
bidirecional o movimento que a liderança
deve acompanhar a questão é
independentemente do tipo de vingança
vou provar excluídas não estão
preparados
não pensamos temos visto até agora
comida deve inspirar pessoas
esta parte tem a ver com o
relacionamento humano que o comitê
também deve ser inspirador e ao mesmo
tempo ajudar tem que perceber as suas
motivações individuais e as motivações
individuais todos vós e potenciar o
coletivo
na prática hoje na abertura como o eixo
da inteligência emocional
william não continua a deixar de fazer o
que faziam
- que é focar as suas decisões as duas
opções estratégicas
pequei para que todos entendamos que é
um resultado atingido há um objetivo
atingir as chamadas estão de operações
do dia a dia da organização
pensemos agora por exemplo se formos um
líder transformacional há vários tipos
de liderança
não vou trazê-los todas aqui seria todo
impossível
hoje por exemplo ganhar um exemplo de
amorim segundo estudiosos nesta área
considera um líder transformacional um
líder transformacional é alguém que é
muito bom nos 3 10
o era transformar sinal segundo ventura
é um visionário típico anti se porque eu
tenho falado com capacidade de pensar
sentir e fusões antes de elas
acontecerem também com uma câmera será a
adaptação fora do comum
vimos isso quando josé mourinho por
exemplo os cofres num jogo em que a
estratégia deu inicial esteja a correr
mal
só precisávamos visão aos 20 minutos de
jogo isso é uma adaptação falou agora
adaptação está aí capacidade de se
adaptar a este punida também é muito bom
na conexão é capaz de gerar e perceber
qual é a diferença entre a comunicação
externa externa ou interna desculpa e
formal e informal
mas ainda assim não está preparado para
estas partes de comunicação por redes
sociais como por exemplo imagine
eficiente
imaginem que mesmo sendo os demônios
thriller e comunicando suas decisões em
participar da mente se eu tivesse tal
exame for sempre os jogos os jogadores
não iriam entender a liderança tem que
perceber que este tipo de tecnologia
gera desafios que não estão preparados
imaginem por exemplo a gente conhece
penso eu de que tanto é que é realizado
com um nível emocional emocional porque
porque é um líder generoso tem a
intenção de ajudar os outros
aliás uma das uma das recentes em uma
das entrevistas que deu a desenvolver um
programa extremamente interessante que é
é por exemplo todas
absurdo a todos os colaboradores nos 32
áreas do estados unidos e no reino unido
podem fazer férias quem de vez que
querem
a única regra que há indivíduos usada é
que esse colaborador tem por ceder por
seu ato a sua decisão e não vai entre
com o resultado coletivo estiver
envolvido no projeto
ainda assim imaginem que nessa situação
este líder conectar via twitter com
todos os seus colaboradores
hoje em dia há ruídos comunicam via
twitter que acontece é que 160
caracteres podem não representar e que o
quer comunicar viaturas ea forma de
comunicar é completamente diferente
temos de ir à liderança carismática
temos aqui não sou foi extremamente
carismática cumprido não foi durante o
período da segunda guerra mundial foi de
planeamento carismático e que após a
segunda guerra mundial deixou de ser a
liderança carismática e tem uma estrela
em sua essência um bom resultado ao fim
de algum tempo o seu discurso a ser
feito no grid no seu comportamento deixa
de fazer sentido as pessoas
esta conexão efetiva e redes sociais com
outras dessas novas tecnologias é
extremamente complexa de fazer porque
porque sentem um princípio de uma
ambição ligação física uma ligação de
uma interação de área com as pessoas
comunicando com uma equipa virtual que
nunca vi e vimos uma vez por ano em
termos físicos é muito diferente ter de
ter uma conexão diária
assim bruno então subi grande questão é
o mesmo e não é termos gestões que não é
exatamente um dizer comstor apenas 90cm
tal para sinalizar a viver é que não tem
necessidade comandar
tentem imputar o crime de acordo com r
milan
contudo nestas áreas da tecnologia
wireless de efetivamente ainda não estão
preparados para apontar que me lembrem
se estas tecnologias
ao mesmo tempo transfiguraram a
comunicação ea interação entre as
pessoas também configurar uma forma como
as organizações estão estruturados
isto é pôr a 20 anos atrás um líder era
ouvida por ser visionário e pelo
conhecimento que tinha desde da questão
e todas as teclas envolvente
hoje em dia quem está na base por norma
têm mais conhecimento do que o líder em
áreas tecnológicas
isso gera um desafio ao líder de servir
um vídeo seu entender é saber antecipar
receber comunicar de forma diferente
além disso o inter hoje qualquer um nós
é visto como primeira etapa no sentido a
crise não é o céu é um neurônio no meio
do cérebro da organização todos os dias
para que tenhamos conhecimento e essa
partilha ativa do conhecimento tem que
ser generosa
um líder tem que saber promover essa
partilha essa ingenuidade dela
a começar pelo conhecimento temos falado
aqui de adaptação falou que queria
ativar nós não houver essa partilha e
não acredito irá queria tirar também
gritava da partilha e deriva da forma
como comunicamos a conexão errada a
partir de não existir mudanças e pela
crítica política das organizações
hoje em dia quando em nota o líder
influenciador nem isso no seu leque e o
seu e sua rede de contactos dentro da
organização
quantos equipes virtuais em que não
lidamos com as pessoas
o bebé é apenas que gera equipa muitas
vezes ao líder informais dessas equipas
comunicam duas vezes o organismo
organismo capacidade de adaptação
essas tecnologias têm uma capacidade de
intervenção brutal
não só as equipes mas os próprios
líderes em si estão aqui
será que efetivamente os líders estão
prontos para saltar do aquário e pensar
fora da caixa e perceber e até conta
suas ações prometidas por essas
tecnologias têm influenciado a
comunicação é questão que eu digo é que
ainda não vamos provar que miami e tudo